with very thinking about what's he doing
right now it's probably being it he's
probably still standing guard in that
room he's just standing there I would I
thought you went back there you just be
standing there thinking about me no all
right what am i doing
helmet key [ __ ] I have not saved since
our last episode so I have a little bit
of anxiety about not saving but I
understand that we weren't because we
didn't need to yet so I'm just like a
little stressed out but I'm fine I have
a lot of bullets I have a shotgun fully
stocked I have a helmet key and I got
some I don't know drugs crime green
herbs crushed up drugs ready to snore it
so I'm good to go
so the first thing I need to do is find
a new place to use my helmet key I think
there was one really close wasn't there
it's upstairs it's upstairs right there
that little door so let's do that first
alright so the first thing I need is oh
god what is that horrible little animals
out there
oh the hunters can you tell me a little
bit more about hunters and how they work
are they like random Jesse my seat hold
on a second no they're in certain spots
they just like once you complete the
residents they kind of fill the mansion
a bunch of them obviously more powerful
one so this is one right I believe so
Oh Oh what is that
Oh oh my god okay there's a shiny thing
on it but I'm afraid to take anything in
this room
no that's back that's back under yeah
that's a dagger yes all right so he's
like following me that ya could probably
take those I got the room I got three
slots now hold off there's a light
switch right here mm-hmm
I could press it but I'm gonna hold off
I'm gonna read this confidential mail
next day is drawing up upon us execute
the following procedures within one week
prompt actions are demanded lore stars
to the estate OS is feet this is all
this secret obtain Bo's raw combat data
against stars collect two embryos of
each mutated specimens as examples
excluding the tyrant
what's the tyrant ensure complete
disposal of the Arklay laboratory
including all personnel and test animals
disguise their deaths as an accident
when the above procedures are executed
report to headquarters for further
instructions for some reason if you are
unable to execute the procedure by the
deadline report immediately in case of
emergency situations report directly to
the extension number five six nine one
good luck umbrella headquarters
umbrellas evil they're like trying to
kill us how much do you know about the
resonable story like overarching
storyline by the way not enough ok I can
move this ok let me just
can I move this - yep okay so I can move
two of these and there's a light switch
but there's an eagle staring at me and I
feel like if I hit that light switch
that Eagles gonna kill me oh there's
another sheet on the other schemes
making you paranoid oh definitely
like why is that it's got laser eyes I
just hit it how much when is the last
time I saved I don't know boys are over
oh that guy's got one eye what's that
something weird happened so it's on and
then when I walk over there a noise
clicks and it blinks
I don't understand
oh there's a okay so there's a red light
here and that blinks so here's what I'm
thinking do I know what I'm thinking
sure when I walk over there it lets the
bird know or something so I need to move
this over to like give it something to
look at I don't know or you can stand on
it to get like the eye out of it or
something yeah
a glowing yellow jewel sits in the eye
would you like to take it out no because
it's blinking and that birds staring at
me like shouldn't I wait yeah that's
something like run
nope [ __ ] damn it
you know I don't get a lot of time he's
staring at me think of him think of him
like a security camera if you want to
avoid security camera where would you go
under it but he's always there know you
you've been walking straight in his
eyeline oh I see so you're saying if I
do this then I get more time before he
moves that's what you're saying
he won't even move if he hug the wall
until toward the end yeah
he found me so can I not take it no take
it now he didn't he didn't see it yeah I
gotcha
Oh get down I mean I didn't think that
through
okay so I got some gemstones here so you
don't want me to take those shells Oh
laughs you have really hand now a savory
was right underneath you you also could
save now I guess been that long I don't
remember
you saved back in those not before we
started this episode it's very alarming
the wall looks suspicious doesn't it it
does yeah actually do you know you could
use the yellow gemstone for I don't know
if you'll remember this this was awhile
ago there was a time when there was like
a lion that had an eye and it said like
an eye for an eye or something yeah you
put the blue one in you sewed the yellow
either that's right
but it only gave me stuff more stuff
okay so you wanna give you well I'll do
that then I don't need all this sorry I
didn't mean to switch them and then
should I put them because I don't know
I don't remember exactly where the stuff
is
you're really close right now it's it's
that hallway where you had to dodge
those two zombies it's really the next
time through this next door around is it
upstairs no it's that tiny little red
room oh yeah good close you literally go
through two doors okay so right around
the bend right left right right right
sorry yeah I did it with the way I
perceive it not the way Jill sees things
[ __ ] [ __ ] I should have saved no you
gotta talk anybody and you have read
Ephesians combined combined what I
listen I'm if if I was dying when this
was happening I'd be freaking out right
here we go shoot car wait think it's up
yup
show yourself
I'm not moving
he'll please
is he dead
god the music sucks is there another one
is so perfectly damn it oh he didn't
hurt you as bad as badly uh yeah yeah
caught you sleeping oh all right I still
think I can get there alive and back
yeah you're where I'm at it's pretty
close so straight what your entire body
reacting to that oh great
what's up with this noise alright so
take a right no left what just yeah go
down the highway and then into the
alcove
this noise some of the noises in this
place is it noisy place I only have four
shotgun bullets left
give me them goods it's like a tyrant mo
desc
I don't know what that is okay good
sweet I think I should bring those back
and then I should save that's what I
think okay sounds good
cool alright so I'm going through that
door right left around the corner got it
got it
God if there's another one of those
things I'm gonna be really mad hunter
yes there they get like two swipes in
it's musics like really foreboding right
now it's just like you're gonna die
see like I don't like it this is hard
it's getting harder all right so I don't
know what to do with that disc should I
put it away yeah I'd like to get more
shotgun shells and combine them that
seems reasonable I'll put those back
when I'm ready and I will save real fast
good to bring with you as long as you
don't like overuse them ovaries what the
shotgun shells well doesn't it takes up
a valuable slot filling up to meas BOTS
right now I mean yeah it's good way of
thinking
so I'm just opening up the rest of the
doors right now yeah because you do have
the battery to go out to the outside
elevator if you wanted to but right but
you think I should go through the doors
first so let's go through those doors
one right in the main hall all right
let's do that so we'll leave okay so
will basically go where we just were
yeah through the dining hall okay oh
mercy [ __ ]
doesn't like third time if someone jumps
to do window dude it's like you'd think
they would have thought of a different
way it's always the windows it's up the
music so I'm taking a right and I'm
going all the way down
what is this the music is so weird
back here for the first time in a while
yeah it has been a really long time what
is behind the floor since the beginning
very okay going up the stairs no no but
that locked doors under do you know the
ones that right yeah under this one
mm-hmm this is exciting I've wanted to
know what was in this one for a long
time
fetuses of course something handwritten
it's not dated nothing's changed I never
thought that this room I designed as an
experiment would pay off like this I can
hide here safely for a while because
nobody knows about the secret behind
this painting not even sir Spencer
painting of a mansion in the back of the
art room secret behind the painting in
the art room where's that
well she got to be so morose about an
elaborately fashioned boob an old tube
of some kind that it no this place is
bigger than I thought okay should I take
that I would not worry about them just
remember they're there
humans are animals we're all animals all
right so let's go down this hallway is
how I walk now should go through it
should you go through a door I don't
like your attitude man that mirror is
misleading I should have changed out of
my shotgun shouldn't I have sorry
whatever I like what's done is done
panics this is a game you know he
doesn't have blood yes he does
yes yes what a cool shot I was like
super confused at first and then I got
it
yeah I've run into him a fair amount of
times such a dumb boy what's that bad
ground the ground - this is where I
always come once the snakes get me will
you take the jewelry box yes yes I will
and I will take that Daddy do you dig
dig and I guess I don't really need
these plants
although I don't have any health right
now so it could probably take a green
one but then I'm pretty full weight you
can't tell me when I do it oh god tell
me like before well on examine the
jewelry box okay oh no sure you gotta go
back to a safe room yeah it's a disc
isn't it mm that I got the red jewel
damn it go yeah yeah okay okay I'm
examining it okay cool so that's done
should I continue on my quest I can't
believe I used a shotgun on that idiot
I could have dodged him - there's no
reason to go back in that room is there
um no not really I must for the blue
orbs but you got a few saved up it's a
bummer like shouldn't use shotgun shells
on that guy no I didn't think it through
honestly nope okay so this room is
pretty much done what about that red
area or should I go to the safe room
first you can go check out what's down
there if you want I will you got one
more door upstairs is it down here
that's it octagonal indentations I don't
know what that means
all right well that's not what I thought
dr. Connell well I know what octagonal
means I don't is I didn't know what to
do with it being a jerk I know I know
I know you're a jerk so should I go to
there that's not the safe room oh no
sorry that's the door that said like the
Oz will Spencer mansion crest right I'm
just trying to see what other ones this
can open upstairs in the East Wing you
have not gone to yet for a while there
we go
that's the one I wanted so that oh okay
there's this area sorry I know what you
have to do okay so you did just save so
I could go back to the item box and I
could open this jewelry box I could do
that now sure I was just saying if I
could open up everything with that key
then I could get rid of that key so the
last door I was gonna do that before I
go yes go upstairs
this last door is a walkway like way up
there I don't know feel remember it
remember that like early on you went
into that room where there's those two
statues that if you remove that fake key
or the key those statues closed on you
yeah there's that one door past that
that was the last helmet door all right
so where we got we're going over here to
where those stairs are at the top yeah
Oh stairs mhm
then if you go up one more floor I think
there's a Zomba near still I can't
remember where all the crimson heads are
there at this point there's not many
the hunters kind of like cuz this dude's
gone - is he where did it go to the
basement probably the labs I don't know
that's weird
alright so mom - the second second door
all the way to the right - correct
correct yes correct that's nice
now you might as well just miss your
inventory sorry I was looking at this
you may just do it now I'm also on
caution I should really just eat this a
sure use go I would say go to the save
room quick to drop a few things off so
then you don't have to make the trip up
to the stairs and back again but I I'm
telling you just let me go downstairs
now yeah go to this shortcut at the end
of the hallway the one you use the last
episode and then go back down to the
save room yet alright got some action
coming up mmm
I'm fine with no action I just don't
stay tuned I'm actually pretty good with
like no action at all I'm like fine with
that
we could just not have any action just
wanted their mansion for the next 60
noses
sometimes when I get stressed out in
games that is what I do I don't progress
the story and I just walk around and
mentally decompress that I'm alright so
you do something exciting
how much guidance you want with what to
bring here well I know well actually no
while you're here you'll do it I'm
already here
wait
I only get one on what piece no you just
you can move them all around I thought I
was picking a piece and then r101 rotate
oh I'm doing a puzzle I understand I'm
confused
it's fine Dora Bobby I got this
I wonder if this is like
perfect I don't know what I'm doing
you're trying to fill in that octagon
with these pieces fit them together
so first no first of all it was perfect
these are good just as this how about
make it harder for yourself you keep
doing this that one looks good that
looks like a good spot
come on get that that looks like a good
listen to what I'm saying this looks
like we're gonna spend the entire
episode doing this keeps making that
noise yeah because you keep pressing it
this is okay go to that way yes make
sure when you put them in there set into
it that one was not like lining it up
with the edges don't half-ass it yeah
okay
I try that one at the bottom I think
no can I flip it yeah but no don't go
keep going to back what it was rotating
couple more
that's good just keep going one more
there try that out I'm not sure if it's
correct but wait I'm gonna be correct
but you're trying it like to pick the
pictures on them help as well so line
those up they don't line up
you can also restart it so this one
right here looks like it goes next to
that one on the left like if you match
up there oh that it doesn't though yeah
it does you just got a piece there
already okay I'm telling you it's
literally not gonna let you put it down
Lister you move that piece of there
right you can get there this puzzles
awful like I hate it it's not really a
puzzle but put this back which is
baffling how I don't like yeah there we
go that doesn't fit you know so if it's
this way I mean it can fit anyway you're
just you don't have the right pieces
already in
I'm telling you restart like it's
driving me crazy I'm gonna leave the
room restart the entire puzzle all right
how do I restart it quit the puzzle yes
now you gonna combine it again oh I had
to combine them again all right this is
it
I feel good about this pay attention
it's like the markings on them on the
pieces yeah okay go to that biggest
piece the bottom-left that looks like
it's the but if you flip it keep going
that right there that looks like the
bottom of the crust yeah I guess and
that one right not this one but yeah
don't I mean do it that was possible no
wait
yeah that's the only way it fits now I
think about it is like that right that
seems like that seems right
it is hard
you probably like this is the easiest
goddamn puzzle in the game Mary cause
like this like you're saying the piece
of it like I would say it it looks good
there ya know get rid us one let's go to
that one yeah what that that once what
yeah so now put that up there it looks
like it lines up with those it does it's
definitely these are upright they're not
gonna end up being upright did we [ __ ]
up at some point
oh we did okay it just might not have to
be um why won't it fit in the little
hole okay cool
this is not in there perfectly in my I
might have been wrong with those
matching out you might have been cuz
like
if that's a wing right there then this
is a wing yeah or something right yeah I
hate this puzzle so much I always look
it up because I want to take the time to
do it I'm pretty sure that one right
there's the center that cross oh right
that could be completely wrong now that
seems reasonable but then one of these
other pieces is messed up right yeah I
don't know
should we start over again sure I [ __ ]
up I'm sorry
it's hard and stupid okay it's hard it's
just unwieldy it's tedious all right let
me use my thinking brain
well how about I tell you where one
piece goes and you can go from there all
right this sounds good
take that one rotate it yeah yeah yes
all right that's not worth it now go
from there so imagine the crest like
rotated diagonally feet the head should
be the top left that makes sense yeah
don't need more about the head really I
feel like I should have done this part
later no nope chef it yeah the telling
one is that little too one of them sorry
you're good [ __ ] you don't you do that
to me
I hate went okay here we go piece to the
right yeah this way got this little hook
it's a little hook on it it's actually
not never mind
ignore that rotate once yeah that looks
right and then you can figure it out
from here yeah I hate this [ __ ]
that looks right okay [ __ ] that I look
that up I hate it's puzzle come come get
me come after me if you don't like it
okay cool oh really
no and I really it felt like it might
have it I don't be so sad I don't know
what it is
Oh dispenser family crest okay I know
where that goes you got it man
so I got two keys I got all right cool
all right well I got a lot going on for
me um don't you need the key right now
if you're gonna go use the last tell me
key
all right so how much do you want me to
tell you about what to bring right here
what for the last helmet for the helmet
game yeah I probably want this medal of
Eagle no this is No so I don't have a
lot of stuff yeah you do um oh ooh this
square no it's I'm not talking about
like specific items I'm talking about
like firepower oh you don't like what am
I about to [ __ ] go down well I'm
gonna save anyway right yeah I just
don't you get all the way up there and
then realize you don't have what you
need to kill somebody
yeah well I think I should probably take
a first-aid spray mm-hmm
and I'm gonna save right now like I said
you didn't you say pretty recently did I
yeah you'll be fine yeah yeah say if you
got a few engrams left in that art
gallery and then I saved you say it was
semi recently but I yeah you're right no
no no you should save I'm telling you
you just don't want to do that puzzle
again I don't want do the puzzle I don't
want to yeah pretty much that cuz I I
saved really not very long ago I know
but this is more pertinent right to be
good a good episode
you mean when we finish this part like
this yeah the rest of this episode would
be good every other potentially
catastrophic but every episodes no wait
go back
oh right you want me to bring like some
I usually bring my grenade launcher to
this thing I'm gonna see at Iran aren't
I
I wonder what it's like six sounds good
you also don't need the ink ribbon and
you need more than six I would say bring
your the acid ones give a bunch of acid
rounds wouldn't bring your handgun ammo
acid shells
crap sorry it's not what I meant to do I
can't imagine how good I'll be in a
fight alright that's a lot um so you're
gonna get rid of the key when you unlock
it just in case bring your bring like
your grenade shells to I don't
I have 18 grenades you're not you don't
trust a new string oh my god
bring those you have more than six
grenade shells yours they're scattered
do that more than that you may owe you
may to combine them yeah six somewhere
okay that should be good just to be safe
holy crap what am i doing alright so
where we going you're not gonna need all
that you'll be fine it's just I can't
hurt cuz you're walking so far upstairs
that it's gonna be kind of annoying to
come back down actually not that far
from where you're going going down this
hallway toward the camera yeah the same
trick I used to get in but you're going
up those stairs to the back this is
where those first crimson heads were
they're gone now
though I think this is the door no is
this the broken door so many doors
okay so where am I going other side of
this wall up the stairs okay that's the
fakie you put into Indiana Jones that
thing yes there's no music in here
there's nothing
it's very foreboding no what if a shark
with legs just came at you such a cool
shot is it through the window through
the window is the road less traveled I
wouldn't pick up the Serbs I might need
them what the hell was that those books
are about the eternal question of life
and death wait check your inventory
bring one of those herbs oh my god
things should go smoothly Anders you
know doomsday scenario kind of look
who's back run run run run run run
yeah oh no I killed that snake you
didn't die Richard killed him eh
but then he ate Richard and you escaped
yeah okay see that bookshelf at least
win or else no don't face the giant
snake fate head-on
well I can't move past it yeah you can
there's a whole bookshelf right here and
also use your grenade launcher but
you're going toward him so what you want
to do is try to get him to chase you so
then when you round the bookshelf his
towel is so on you're citing to be to
shoot it you mean oh my god I'm on
caution already don't worry about it
well I should probably no don't need a
plan you're fine you literally have a
bookshelf he can run around with it go
the other way wait till he's like you
bait him one way well you're going so
far out he's probably getting ready
where is he how do I know
just wait oh I see him okay he's coming
this way now go around the other side
and you could see his tail and shoot a
surprising
I didn't chase him fast enough so where
is he just keep same direction he's
gonna keep chasing you like that as long
as you go is that a good time yeah but
he might be yeah oh you got a balance in
there you go you got it you just got a
balance to see don't get too close to
him so he doesn't turn around am i
hitting him and hitting him yeah you did
he's like bleeding [ __ ] I see you got
too close there but it's fine just do
the same thing just gotta give him time
to chase you
honestly a thing about resi Liam's big
bosses are very often like running
around something I [ __ ] up I actually
don't know where he is now you could
definitely tell right here
don't get too close [ __ ]
Rizzy good you can get that right here
no I can't
ah he tricked me his tail is gonna be
right around the bookshelf oh sorry I
missed sorry I thought like I would
doesn't have much range to be honest so
you gotta yeah really Wow
oh you can get him thank you
oh my god I don't think you're in as
much danger as you think you are you can
get that [ __ ]
I'm sorry she like I'm not very good at
this it's alright good oh my god
yeah yeah oh you there's around
twelve you shouldn't need more than
three he's not gonna come around you
gotta get ready he's coming toward you
right now nice
okay this is good here we go Scott him
kind of closer
he tricked me he tricked me there's that
first day when you get a chance all
right good
where is he yes yes I can yeah you can
it's there's no there's no like probably
two more tops
he's on the side
damn I can't I'm too close keep chasing
no like that's the problem you can't if
if you're if he's wrapped around the
corner he's not gonna he's coming this
way
oh no no your that's why I did it I
don't know you gotta just keep just stay
close in right here he's around the
corner your good cheer tale in victory
[ __ ] you yawn [ __ ] you feels good oh
that's a grenade launcher that is giant
snake got nothing there's a bronze
trophy it's not that the game's not that
impressed Oh [ __ ] annoying that snake
just never died
the snake that refused to die yeah the
same name of the other book except it's
blue
a medal was hidden inside the book and
there's a wolf on it okay okay now you
can get that better you can use outside
for one oh yeah let's do that real fast
anything else in here that I should be
aware of is there like an upstairs mm
just that's it's read probably cuz their
lives at the beginning you can't get if
you want but okay so that's just a
broken door yeah so what that's through
that's to the main no that's where you
went for the battery all right so where
am I going back to savory released and
they're gonna go outside why do I need
what it was see a room cuz you might as
well take those herbs while you're here
oh yeah if that snake comes back alive
I'm gonna be pissed
I wonder oh yeah you took another way
yeah
what no I didn't use it I used spray cuz
I got mm-hmm cuz you got it sorry I just
I feel like one of those little [ __ ]
is gonna like jump out at me or
something that's just too quiet you know
I hate that area usually your grenade
launcher out I do
dude that's that paranoid now I really
don't believe that nothing's going to
kill me it's good I have no good feeling
not for right now just this game in
gentlemen all right so taking a left do
the shortcut door again through the
shortcut door
oh you have dispenser yes should I do
that now yeah you could just save time
you could just go and see that or the
backpack you could go back through this
alright sorry go to follow this follow
this hallway around get to the dining
room uh-huh
and then just go across to the upper up
side of the East Wing and then go down
those stairs get to the East Wing save
room it's a bit of a trek but it'd be
closer to Spencer door so here or
something
it's weird there's no zombie here I like
almost boys was comforted knowing he was
here you know now it's like I'll imagine
seems dormant even though there are
hunters everywhere well alright so oh my
god just across the East Wing going
across to this one no the other one yeah
that's where you originally got the
grenade launcher forest was out there
like was his hobby was his name
forest mm-hmm would you say Forest has
given up the ghost he's given up the
ghost
and then down the stairs yeah
for the zombie bus through that door I
oh my god there's still a zombie in here
dodging I thought all of them were gone
bait him to one side
I can't I [ __ ] it up
let's go through a door and reset it
them or kill him after you
yeah I can fix this Odin I use the
grenade lock you could that be over
Kayla be satisfying weak they call you
the overkill killer does it take one
acid grenade to take out a zombie I
think so last time I checked but I still
save them
nice
yeah that door feel like you'd have a
good sense of the mansion yeah no I
really don't I feel like I'm constantly
nice with the maps for I still feel like
I make guesses all the time all right so
we're gonna try to do the battery and
the key right now no just one I would
even say we can make this a shorter
episode caller right here
the next part oh you know you can do the
key and then battery next episode okay
the battery I'll put this away you don't
need a grenade launcher anymore for now
you made me bring so much I should
probably bring the handgun ammo them
Spencer key oh right that's done okay
here we go I'm running at a save ribbons
honestly you still got three in that art
room to the main hall
don't go through the it's pretty much
straight across the story you can use
this door without breaking it now oh
right
Barry fixed it mm-hmm the handyman he is
he's shady he might he won't try to kill
us all but talking to himself he fixed
that door gazing him oh no okay I heard
it I'll try to uh could I just dodge him
no I can't he'll disappear it good try
no he appears remember no this is where
you killed the first one then why is he
here again at least get out the shotgun
I only have eight I forgot to add more
they only take three
wait till he gets up [ __ ] you again crap
I was gonna combine you remember you
never killed him you thought there was
still one so you escaped this dude went
through the door and fought the savory
one so this dude was this is the first
hunter you saw oh he dead no okay so the
doors right there [ __ ] am i going right
next to yes it's a battery pack to you
right I can't take it
not until I turn on a light
yes
yes all right
is that it yeah
examine that object muffiny it's gonna
reveal anything yeah they're mine okay
I have a lot of these two of them two of
these well one of these ones the other
ones still in the door that you need to
get back toward to the outside and I
guess that's it yeah can't go back to
the same room call it an episode and the
next time we are snake can't believe he
lived so I'm just taking away what
didn't you pick up in there
oh no [ __ ] go back you did not pick
everything up oh-ho it's good that it
was red though gonna say [ __ ] I forgot
your door to your left
yeah yeah all right sweet
that was a close one that's actually two
hundreds you can kill with six shells
potentially considering like if I do it
right so do I just take a left here and
that's it yeah saver it's pretty
convenient but I'm like out of save
ribbons if I'm more and then there's
three more in that art room if you ever
need them
so would you have it in your inventory
for next steps oh yeah drop that for now
I'll reload with those first oh right
good to get out of inventory I have it's
a box so I'm pretty much done okay so
that's done writing did the battery
actually no just don't worry about that
yeah we'll do the next episode just safe
well I'm gonna take the battery now that
way I'm like that's what I was doing the
battery see this is my last ink ribbon
yeah but there's still two spots I know
you have six more alright isn't it
mm-hmm
alright I like saving it's my favorite
things we done good on the next episode
of resident Knievel I wonder how far I
am into this
I feel like I'm getting close I got
unlocked all the doors make good
progress
I've done pretty good cool well thank
you guys for joining us do not forget to
Like and subscribe these videos we can
do more of this kind of stuff we were
going through all of the Resident Evil
series well hopefully number two finish
the first one
let's try to get through the pilot
through let's try to get through the
first one alright see you guys
you